[Music]
he is someone who doesn't take easily to
compliments
but he has quite simply been my strength
and stay all these years
and i and his whole family
and this and many other countries owe
him a debt greater than he would ever
claim or we shall ever know
although it's a time of great happiness
and good chair for many
christmas can be hard for those who have
lost loved ones
this year especially i understand why
but for me in the months since the death
of my beloved philip
i have drawn great comfort from the
warmth and affection of the many
tributes to his life and work
from around the country the commonwealth
and the world
his sense of service
intellectual curiosity
and capacity to squeeze fun out of any
situation
were all irrepressible
that mischievous inquiring twinkle
was as bright at the end as when i first
set eyes on him
but life of course consists of final
partings as well as first meetings
and as much as i and my family miss him
i know he would want us to enjoy
christmas
we felt his presence as we like millions
around the world readied ourselves for
christmas
while kobe it again means we can't
celebrate quite as we may have wished
we can still enjoy the many happy
traditions be it the singing of carols
as long as the tune is well known
decorating the tree
giving and receiving presents
or watching a favorite film where we
already know the ending it's no surprise
that families so often treasure their
christmas routines
we see our own children and their
families embrace the roles traditions
and values that mean so much to us
as these are passed from one generation
to the next
sometimes being updated for changing
times
i see it in my own family and it is a
source of great happiness
prince philip was always mindful of this
sense of passing the battle
that's why he created the duke of
edinburgh's award
which offers young people throughout the
commonwealth and beyond the chance of
exploration and adventure
it remains an astonishing success
grounded in his faith in the future
he was also an early champion
of taking seriously our stewardship of
the environment
and i am proud beyond words that his
pioneering work has been taken on and
magnified by our eldest son charles and
his eldest son william
admirably supported by camilla and
catherine
most recently at the cop climate change
summit in glasgow
next summer we look forward to the
commonwealth games
the baton is currently traveling the
length and breadth of the commonwealth
heading towards birmingham
a beacon of hope on its journey
it will be a chance to celebrate the
achievements of athletes and the coming
together of like-minded nations
and february just six weeks from now
we'll see the start of my platinum
jubilee year
which i hope
will be an opportunity for people
everywhere to enjoy a sense of
togetherness
a chance to give thanks for the enormous
changes of the last 70 years
social
scientific and cultural
and also to look ahead with confidence
i'm sure someone somewhere today will
remark that christmas is a time for
children
it's an engaging truth but only half the
story
perhaps it's truer to say that christmas
can speak to the child within us all
adults when weighed down with worries
sometimes fail to see the joy in simple
things where children do not
and for me and my family
even with one familiar laugh missing
this year there will be joy in christmas
as we have the chance to reminisce
and see anew the wonder of the festive
season
through the eyes of our young children
of whom we were delighted to welcome
four more this year
they teach us all a lesson
just as the christmas story does
that in the birth of a child there is a
new dawn with endless potential
it is this simplicity of the christmas
story
that makes it so universally appealing
simple happenings that form the starting
point of the life of jesus
a man whose teachings have been handed
down from generation to generation
and have been the bedrock of my faith
his birth marked a new beginning
as the carol says
the hopes and fears of all the years
are met in the tonight
i wish you all a very happy christmas
[Music]
oh christ is
[Music]
and praises sing to
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]